we begin with some historic news India
has become the first country in the
world to successfully land a craft near
the moon's South Pole prime minister
Narendra Modi was watching the mission
from South Africa and congratulated the
team back home let's take a closer look
at why there's been a rise in interest
in the moon's Southern pole well the
area is said to be home to Frozen water
which could be a source of drinking
water fuel and oxygen for future Moon
Explorations but attempts to land on the
surface of the Moon had proven
challenging that was until now
is not alone
this is a year
in which
the world is witnessing
India G20 presidency
our approach of
one Earth
one family
one future
is resonating
across the globe
this human Centric approach
that we present
and that will represent
had been
welcome
universally
our moon mission
is also based on the same human Centric
approach
therefore
this success
belongs to
all of humanity
in 2019 India's chandragan II spacecraft
attempted to touch down but failed rough
terrain was cited as one of the reasons
and just a few days ago Russia's first
mission to the Moon in nearly 50 years
ended with disappointment after its
lunar 25 spacecraft crashed on Landing
well for more on this we're going to
bring in Anil kumabat who is director
general of the Indian space Association
it's an industry Association for Indian
space and satellite manufacturing
companies he joins us now from New Delhi
thank you very much for being on Al
Jazeera once again first of all can you
explain to us the mood around the
country uh the win it was confirmed that
the Lander had indeed indeed touched
down successfully
you know it's a historic and special
moment for our space not only for space
but for everyone in India there were
more than a billion Hearts which were
beating louder and faster waiting for
this very critical last 20 minutes of
the Lander coming down and we are so
proud of our scientists that they have
been able to achieve it and do it well
this time and land it softly on the moon
I'm here in a college a little away from
Delhi and my God the excitement the
happiness has seen with students uh as
if every we won a World Cup match or
something yeah
everybody's so excited the pictures from
the mission control were remarkable when
it was confirmed that it had indeed
touched down I guess how significant is
this going to be uh for the Indian space
industry as well as the wider economy
tree which is in a very nascent stage
now
is will be built up on the Heritage
attacks from Israel and whatever ISRO
achieves will get passed down to our
space industry players it is already
happening they are doing transfer of
Technology of satellites uh Rockets are
now being made with private players like
the pslv and many more things even our
startups who have attempted a launch
support has all the information so
isro's scientific success is a step
forward for the industry also and as all
of us say in the future there will be a
lunar economy led by space stations and
colonies on the boom and who knows in
the future mining
or if not mining Moon becomes the base
for going Beyond into the universe yeah
and for all that
all space fairing nations are going to
go together and Israel's achievement
here is a is a very positive step for
the Indian space industry I guess I want
to know how ambitious uh India is when
it does come to space exploration
doesn't want to compete with the likes
of Russia and China and America and as
you say uh push the boundaries and go
beyond to Mars
oh oh yes the thing is the most
important part of ISRO has been and like
the present the current chairman says
one step at a time and the present two
steps which they're looking at is uh
human Mission which is the gaganya
uh Mission very immediately maybe next
month where there will be at the mission
who won it of the Sun but all steps are
being taken one by one as I know today
for some of the planet there is no
Mission which has been laid down but in
the future and with the success which
has been achieved that will really
happen and of course Indian space
journey has been with allies with
friends with Partners from France
to Japan to USA to USSR and now Russia
and many other Australia now many
countries even UK we we've been all
cooperating in this space journey so
that is why this this landing on the
southern part of the Moon which we've
been successful is
good for the entire scientific community
of the whole world yeah certainly is a
very exciting time when it comes to
space exploration thank you so much uh
that is
director general of the Indian space
Association thanks very much for being
on Al Jazeera thank you thank you